j'ai rose nour cyrénée présidente de
rédaction média spécialiste de la
turquie
bonsoir 11 nour sirène et merci de
répondre à nos questions comment
repartir sur de bonnes bases entre paris
et ankara après les tensions en mai
revenant orientale en ce qui concerne
les hydrocarbures après les points de
vue divergent sur la syrie sur la libye
après également le rapport à l'islam
depuis le meurtre de samuel pâtit
comment repartir de l'avant
bonsoir tout d'abord merci beaucoup pour
votre invitation
aujourd'hui la rencontre du ministre que
mes doutes chaouch au dos avec son
homologue français jean yves le drian et
faisait suite à une entretien du
président tout les jedi pardonne avec
son homologue français manuel mois
chrono mois de mars afin de normaliser
les relations comme vous avez évoqué
dans le résumé
malheureusement les deux pays vivent un
certain nombre de divergences d'opinion
et de position dans différents régions
du monde à la fois sur le plan
géopolitique mais aussi sur un certain
nombre de questions liées à la politique
intérieure de la france
donc quelles sont ces régions où les
deux pays ville des divergences
d'opinion et de position c'est
principalement la libye la syrie et la
méditerranée orientale le caucase du sud
et quels sont les autres questions
autour desquelles les deux pays
s'opposent c'est plutôt principalement
le rôle de la turquie au sein de l'otan
l'adhésion de la turquie à l'ue à
l'européen et mais aussi l approche du
gouvernement de marc honte vis-à-vis de
l'islam et des musulmans et aussi le
traitement des freins peux-tu par le
gouvernement deux mois aujourd'hui la
turquie souhaite normaliser ses
relations avec la france
donc à lui tend la main pour l'heure
quasi toutes ces tensions et parce que
les deux pays ont des intérêts à commun
à partager et dans toutes ces régions et
dans toutes ces questions donc si vous
me permettez je souhaiterais et résumé
un parent les confiance de pays et
comment des deux pays pour trouver des
points communs et des antilles
recommande dans ces régions des dans ces
questions
tout d'abord en syrie et qu'on vous le
savez la turquie était parti de l'otan
donc c'est un allié de la france au sein
de l'otan et ainsi réunion de l'otan
prochainement un donc cette réunion
tombe au bon moment
allez-y du coup pas par rapport à votre
explication
oui tout à fait merci beaucoup donc un
série et qu'on vous le savez comme j'ai
dit là la turquie fait partie de l'otan
et la turquie et la syrie partagent une
frontière de plus de 800 kilomètres et
donc la turquie et et c'est l'un des
pays les plus affectés par la guerre
civile qui est qui et qui est lui qui a
lieu en syrie depuis 2011
et donc il ya deux menaces contre la
turquie c'est d'un flux migratoires mais
aussi des menaces terroristes
edf est aussi des breaks pg donc en tant
que membre de l'otan et la turquie et
souhaite à la fois préservé pour les
gens qui ne savent pas ce que c'est ce
sont les combattants kurdes que ankara
considère comme terroriste mais qui ont
combattu les
le groupe etat islamique aux côtés
notamment des américains et pour la
turquie et c'est une extension du groupe
terroriste pkk qui est aussi reconnu
comme un groupe terroriste à la fois par
l'union européenne et les etats-unis est
mais pour justement la france c'est ce
sont des alliés ou combattre des neiges
et mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé en
syrie donc la nature qui visait à la
fois à combattre et des chevilles aussi
des grecs pg mais aussi à assurer la
sécurité de ses frontières mais aussi à
créer une zone de sécurité et en syrie
pour lui le tueur sécuriser des rues
puget syriens qui sont actuellement sur
le sol turc et nature qui c'est le pays
qui accueille le plus grand nombre de
réfugiés au monde avec à peu près
environ quatre millions de réfugiés
syriens
donc la turquie a organisé différentes
différentes opérations de antiterroriste
en syrie mais malheureusement la france
a préféré être aux côtés des grecs pg au
lieu de se tenir sur nos liens au sein
de l'otan et en prétextant nous
lutterons tech donc la première dimanche
divergences entre les deux pays concerne
justement cette politique syrien et
malheureusement la france souhaite
continuer sa collaboration avec les
grecs pg au lieu de comprendre les
préoccupations et les intérêts de la
turquie dans cette région et
deuxièmement donc en libye entre deux
fois et on vous avait évoqué
malheureusement le président de marque
honda a évoqué plusieurs fois mauvaise
politique turque dans cette région qui
déstabiliserait la flic aimé c'est pas
tout c'est pas vraiment le cas au
contraire la turquie a contribué
positivement et à la stabilité du pays
en soutenant depuis le début le
gouvernement d'union nationale reconnue
par la communauté internationale alors
que le gouvernement de marcoing d'un
soutenu les forces de du maréchal en
retard donc qui était considéré comme
langue française dans la position
française est très ambiguë par rapport à
la libye d'ailleurs emmanuel macron a
reçu à la fois coup sur coup face à rage
quand il était à la tête justement du
gouvernement d'union nationale
on a changé de 2
deux leaders en ce qui concerne cela il
a reçu également après effectivement le
maréchal rallye faf tard donc difficile
de
de voir la politique française en libye
cette mais bien évidement c'est une
politique ambiguë mais on voyait quand
même le proximité avec le maréchal en
salles depuis le début alors que la
turquie a clairement soutenu le
gouvernement d'union nationale même en
fait elle apporte une aide militaire que
la france a condamné donc finalement
c'est la turquie à coude à contribuer à
la stabilité du pays
alors que le mal à celle installée
actuelle allemande accusée de crimes de
guerre par de nombreuses ong mais mais
emmanuel macron a condamné les
combattants mercenaires turcs notamment
par rapport l'année lunaire beaucoup de
points de divergence
vous avez évoqué la syrie on évoque la
libye mais concrètement aujourd'hui
entre entre jean yves le drian et
amusez-vous chase au look et qu'est ce
qui s'est dit selon vous pour essayer
d'aplanir justement toutes ces
divergences
enfin enfin les deux pays peuvent
trouver des points communs et un coût du
chauffage je répète c'est la france
devrait accepter que la turquie n'est
pas une rivale ou une ennemie au
contraire ce pays alliés au sein de
l'otan c'est un pays candidat à l'ue un
européen donc et en plus la france le
problème de la france est de jamais
comprend des deux prendre en
considération les préoccupations de la
turquie au sujet de la lutte contre le
terrorisme et aussi leurs flux
migratoires aujourd'hui elle a tout
intérêt à collaborer avec la turquie
c'est aller justement d'empêcher
l'afflux migratoire et sécuriser les
frontières de l'ue à l'européen donc ça
sert à rien de ça c'est un levier de
pression de la part d'ankara vis-à-vis
de bruxelles vis-à-vis de paris et de
berlin
ce n'est pas une levée de pression ne
peux pas l'appeler comme ça parce que
elle toujours en fait on le qualifie
comme l'ailé de pressions de la part du
gouvernement turc alors que la turquie
fait des efforts considérables des noms
des noms des efforts pour l'accueillir à
peu près comme je vous dis quatre
millions de réfugiés dont on ne peut pas
parler de chantage de levier de pression
c'est juste en fait pour dire que si
vous continuez à ne pas nous considérer
comme des alliés et en nous voir comme
des ennemis qu'il faut sanctionner et
nous aussi
ont pu aussi on a aussi des moyens de
nous défendre enfin c'est pas séparément
le moyen de pression parce que la
turquie n'a jamais réellement envoyer
ces réfugiés en europe et il ne faut pas
le considérer comme ça et un coût dix
fois la turquie à la france est déjà
pour l'amour dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme la turquie a rapatrié
plusieurs terreuse français qui est à la
frontière syriens dans la france par
exemple et à partager des informations
clés dans la lutte contre le terrorisme
avec la france
donc dans ce domaine les deux pays
collaborent activement et depuis le
début et la collaboration de marche très
bien
donc maintenant dans toutes ces régions
que ce soit en syrie en libye en
méditerranée orientale dans le caucase
du sud les deux pays devraient prendre
devraient trouver des points communs des
alcools et partager la même position
pour développer leur partenariat
et c'est pas quelque chose d'impossible
merci je vous ai dit il ya déjà des
domaines dans lesquels il travaille et
je voudrais quand même évoqué quelques
autres questions qui sont liées à la
politique je suis désolé on n'a plus le
temps ces rennais merci en tous les cas
d'avoir répondu à nos questions il ya
donc des points de convergence quand
même entre paris et ankara on l'a bien
compris les deux ministres des affaires
étrangères turc
les français qui se sont donc vus et qui
appelle à renforcer
alors leurs liens sur la base du respect
mutuel selon les dires donc de mevlüt
cavusoglu tout à l'heure